la semaine prochaine aussi lundi les
pouvoirs publics et les représentants
des instituteurs seront une nouvelle
fois face à face au secrétariat d'état à
la fonction publique il s'agit de
discuter les modalités de la réforme de
la formation des maîtres
en principe cela ne pose pas de problème
insoluble mais sur la négociation de
lundi peizerat une petite phrase elle a
été prononcée par monsieur guy georges
le secrétaire général du syndicat
national des instituteurs monsieur guy
georges qui déclara tf1 si nous
n'obtenons pas une amélioration du
traitement des instituteurs il n'y aura
pas de réformes
une enquête de dominique laurie
indiscutablement malgré une certaine
prudence de part et d'autre les
négociations avancent tout le monde
reconnaît aujourd'hui qu'il faut rénover
en profondeur la formation des maîtres
lentement se dessine les contours de la
réforme
et s'il ya encore des points obscurs on
peut déjà en tracer les grandes lignes
après quatre mois de négociations entre
le ministère et les syndicats notamment
le plus influent le syndicat national
des instituteurs les premiers points
d'accord apparaissent le premier point
d'accord c'est que le contenu de la
formation doit être extrêmement complet
sérieux modernise donc prolongé
probablement prolonger car le profil
professionnel de l'instituteur tels que
nous avons essayé de le tracer exige de
telles connaissances et le teil savoir
faire qu'il faudra probablement aller au
delà de deux ans avec la formation
d'instituteurs ne veut pas être
considérée comme terminée au delà de
deux ans ou deux ans et demi ou même
trois ans elle est permanent et qui dit
formation permanente dit accès à
l'enseignement supérieur
il faut donner à l'élève mettre la
possibilité de voir reconnaître sa
formation pour poursuivre des études
supérieures ultérieure est ce que cette
réforme sera appliquée à la prochaine
entre oui le calendrier est bien fixé
maintenant par le gouvernement et par le
ministre de l'éducation en avril au
printemps ils ont le projet sera prêt
est exposée par le ministre et la
nouvelle formation se mettre en oeuvre
dès septembre 1979
actuellement la formation se déroule
après le baccalauréat en deux ans dans
des écoles normales comme ici à saint
germain mais dans ces établissements qui
viennent de subir des réductions de
postes d'enseignants une certaine
inquiétude se dégage devant une réforme
qui risque de réduire le rôle des écoles
normales
imaginez que depuis la rentrée dernière
on annonce un changement dans la
formation des maîtres qui nous est
toujours inconnue il ya des
répercussions très probable sur les
services des enseignants sur les postes
et nous ne savons même pas comment va
être organisée à la fois la formation
initiale et continue et ce que vous
pourrez occupe seul la sécurité d'emploi
non seulement la sécurité de l'emploi
mais les conditions dans lesquelles nous
pourrons travailler
autre point peut-être le plus difficile
les salaires aujourd'hui à l'instituteur
débute à 2771 francs il reçoit 3625
francs à mi carrière et moins de 5000 en
fin de quart pour le syndicat national
des instituteurs
la négociation est au milieu du gué mais
il reste l'essentiel l'amélioration de
la situation matérielle des enseignants
les choses sont moins avancées etc si
j'ose dire notre moitié du gain alors je
crois qu'il faut être très clair s'il
aventure n'intervenait aucune
amélioration matérielle et en
particulier de nos traitements et bien
il n'y aurait pas de référent je veux
dire aussi que le temps presse et que si
l'on veut vraiment ne pas perdre de
temps c'est très rapidement que le
gouvernement doit arrêter ses choix
ajoutons que le ch'ti réclament une
augmentation des traitements des
instituteurs de 15% environ
nouvelle réunion lundi mais avec la
déclaration de guy georges la balle est
maintenant dans le camp du gouvernement
et puisqu'il s'agit de rallonge
budgétaire c'est probablement le premier
ministre raymond barre qui tranchera
pour ne pas dire l'elysée